جدلا واسع في تونس اثاره حفل زفاف بعد ان
شهدت امراتان على عقد قران فقد شهدت ام
العروس وام العريس على عقد القران كسبقه
في البلاد التي لطالما كان العرف فيها ان
يشهد رجلان على الزواج كما هو الحال في
باقي الدول العربيه كما ان الماذون الذي
عقد القران ايضا كان امراه في القانون
التونسي ووفقا الفصل الثالث في الاحوال
الشخصيه يشترط لصحه الزواج شهاده شاهدين
من اهل الثقه دون تحديد جنس الشهيدين ما
يعني انه لا يوجد اي شيء يمنع بالقانون ان
يكون الشهود من النساء وبهذا يكون هذا
الحفل لم يتجاوز القانون والده العروس و
احدى الشاهدتين هي الكاتبه والمؤلفه
والباحثه التي اشتهرت بالجراه في كتاباتها
وبطروحاتها الاحداثيه كما تناولت فيها
ابحاثها الموروث الديني بالتحليل
والمقارنه
[موسيقى]
كل حال الناس في تونس عن رايهم في عقد
القران الذي شهدت عليهم امراه ثانيه
العيله صحه العقل انا معلم وسويت الكامله
بين الرجل والمراه في جميع في الحقوق
والواجبات
ونبقى في تونس معنا من هناك الكاتبه
والمؤلفه والباحثه الدكتوره الفا يوسف
دكتوره الفا يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في
صباح العربيه ونتشرف باستضافتك اليوم في
صباح العربيه اولا
صباح الانوار لك ولكل المشاهدات
والمشاهدين والشرف لي سيدتي والف مبروك
كمان لابنتك الله يخليك الله يهني الجميع
خلينا نحكي بالعرف
يقتضي حضور شاهدين من الرجال هذه السابقه
هل هي تمرد ام رساله
اولا همم
تكون الامور واضحه هذه ليست اول مره تشهد
فيها امراه على عقد الزواج في تونس لكن
ربما من المرات القلاء التي كان شهد
التالي امراتين وضابطه الحاله المدنيه
التي كتبت العقده
ليس هناك اي شيء يمنع من ان يكون الشاهد
على عقد الزواج امراه او رجل في تونس
المواطن
والمواطنه لهما نفس الحقوق والواجبات
وكلاهما يدفع الضرائب للدوله وكلاهما
يشتغل ويطبق القوانين في هذه الحاله كان
هناك عروس وعريس يريدان ان يكرم امهما
وهنا هناك خلط في اذهان الناس كنت استمع
الى احاديث الجماعه كلمه العرف تكررت
والتربيه والعادات العادات ليست مقدسه
العادات هي اشياء يمكن ان نفكر فيها وان
نراجعها والدليل اننا في البلدان العربيه
الاسلاميه تقريبا جميعا لنا قدس خاصه للام
الجنه تحت اقدام الامهات نحب الامهات ندعو
الى كسبناهم ولكن عندما يتعلق الامر بحفل
الزواج وعقمه العقل الزواج تتاخر الام
ويتقدم الاب
همم يعني
ليس لي اي اشكال في عقود فيها الاب يكون
شاهدا لكن هناك العروسين هما ان نفسهما
يعني الرجل والمراه ابنتي وزوجها رغبه في
ان تكون الشاهده هي الام هذا الشخص الذي
يرعاهما واهتم به الى اخره ليس هناك اي
شيء يمنع قانونيا ولا حتى شرعا لانه في
الشرع المعاملات الماليه هي التي فيها
مشكله رجل وامراتان وما الى ذلك وفيها
اجتهادات متعدده ليس هذا مجالها حتى شرعا
ابن تيميه وغيره كثيرون
شهاده المراه في عقد الزواج عن النحو
تاخرنا كثيرا لطرح مثل هذه القضايا
واعتبارها امرا غريبا وعجيبا لو كان العقد
فيه اربع رجال لضابط حاله مدنيه وشهدات
والزوج لما كان هناك اشكال ولا نتساءل
الناس اين المراه طب دكتوره الفا حضرتك
كتبتي منذ عقود وانت تتحدثين عن مساله
المساواه بين المراه والرجل هل تعتبرين
بانك جسدتيها في زفاف ابنتك
وحاول قدر الامكان ان اكون موافقه لما
اقول في افكارك وهذا ليس بسيطه لانه كل
المفكرين وجل المفكرين احيانا تجدهم
يقولون كلاما وفي حياتهم الشخصيه يمارسون
اقتناعات الاخرى هذه المبادره الى جانب
انها كانت رغبه من ابنتي وزوج ابنتي هي
بالنسبه لي تشتيم الحيض لما اؤمن به
لاعتقاد العميق ان المساواه هي جوهر
الاخلاق وهي جوهر مقاصد الشريعه الاسلاميه
وهي جوهر التعايش بين الرجل والمراه
القائم على الموده والرحمه وان يكون
كلاهما عنصر فاعلا في المجتمع دون اي صراع
ودون تقديم همم جنس على جنس دكتوره الفصه
يعني قلت رغبه من ابنتي ورغبه من زوج
ابنتي عندما طرحتهم الفكره على اهل العريس
ماذا كان موقفهم رد فعلهم في هذا الخصوص
ما اسعدني كثيرا هو ان اعاده وليس عاده في
كثير من العائلات لو طرحت هذه الفكره فاب
العريس وابى العروس وما الذي سينزعجان
ويقولان ماذا سيقول الناس عنا تركنا
زوجاتنا هن اللواتي يشهدن وما بين ذلك من
العقليات السائده في البلدان العربيه
بالعكس بالنسبه لهذه الحاله ساعدت بان
زوجي الذي لا اعرفه من زمان وهو ايضا كاتب
الاستاذ عادل الخضر وهو يؤمن بالمساواه
جسده هذا ايضا لم يكن له اي اشكال
يعني ابو زوج ابنته ايضا وافق بكل سرور
على هذا لكي يكون ذلك اجلالا للمراه والام
وبيانا ان لا معربه لشهاده المراه مع
القانون ولا معارضه لها مع الاخلاق ولا مع
الموده عندما تكون هناك موده والفه وحب
داخل الاسره هذه لتصبح اشياء ثانويه
يطرحها البعض ويجعلون منها مجال للجدل
والمساله كبرت جدا في تونس ويتلقى رسائل
عديده تناقش وتحلل انا سعيده سعيده بان
طرح هذه المساله حتى نفكر فيها ونتبين كيف
ان العرف احيانا يقودنا الى اشياء لا
علاقه لها لا بالعقل ولا بالمنطق ولا
بالاخلاق ولا حتى باجتهادات متنوعه في
مجال الشرعيه
قال بان الحكايه هذه مرت يعني بدون ضجه
كبرى في تونس في التحديد هل تعتقدين بانه
هذا مؤشر معطاء ايجابي انا
هو في تونس الحقيقه منذ سنوات ومنذ حتى في
القرون الوصفه لان الصديق القيرواني وما
الى ذلك بسالك المساواه بين الرجل والمراه
مطروحه نعم هناك تصدق الاجتماعي هناك خوف
اجتماعي لان هذه المساواه بدات فعلا تتجسم
بنسبه كبيره في الواقعه المساله تثير ضجه
في الكلام والحديث والحوار ولكن بما ان
القانون وهو الفيصل بين الناس يسمح بذلك
فلا يمكن ان يتعدى الكلام مجرد الجدد لذلك
ادع دائما في الانف نفسه الى تطوير
القوانين والى تطوير العقليات يدا بيد وكل
واحد يؤثر في الاخر يعني في تونس القوانين
المتقدمه جدا القوانين المتقدمه اكثر
العقليات ولكنها تؤثر في العقليات
والاشتغال يجب ان يكون على المجالين
المجال القانوني التشريعي من جهه والمجال
الاجتماعي النفسي من جهه الاخرى لان
العقليات تحتاج وقتا لتطور واين كنا واين
اصبحنا هناك تطور كبير جدا والامر يستوجب
قرون يعني نحن في حاجه الى نضال مستمر حتى
ترسخ هذه الفكره وبدات تنسخ شيء الى
الحديقه
يوسف شكرا لك